secretary Castro do you determine the
number of people pouring through pouring
into our country to be a national crisis
and what is your solution thank you very
much for the question yeah I believe
that we have a crisis of leadership if
you think about it for a second when he
came into office Donald Trump said that
he was going to solve this as he put at
this immigration problem and he's
completely failed last month there were
144 thousand people that came to the
southern border and in our name little
children have been separated from their
mothers people right now about a hundred
people are in the hundred degree degree
heat of El Paso Texas underneath a
bridge being fenced in and kept like
animals together without the ability to
shower or to change clothes for a whole
month
that is the failure that this president
has been on the issue of immigration
right
so I say that we've tried his cruelty
and his mistakes there's a better way to
do this and a couple of months ago I
released what I call my people first
immigration plan that says number one
that we need to treat people with
compassion and with common sense instead
of cruelty that we need to we need what
what the undocumented immigrants who are
in the United States as long as somebody
hasn't committed a serious crime on a
pathway to citizenship including our
dreamers that we need to invest in an
immigration judiciary that is
independent and has enough judges and
support staff to actually go through all
of the claims for asylum so that people
are not waiting in limbo years upon
years I mean people are out there in the
country just waiting all right we can do
a better job than that and maybe most
importantly we actually need to get to
the root cause of this issue and the
root cause of this issue is that in
places like Honduras like Watto mala
like El Salvador that people can't find
safety or opportunity they're in their
home country
and so that's why a mother would bring
her six month old infant
more than a thousand miles on a
dangerous journey to the southern border
of the United States without any
guarantee of getting in because they're
so desperate it's so dangerous so I've
called for the equivalent of a 21st
century Marshall Plan based on you tool
respect and working together with these
countries and with Mexico so that people
can find that safety an opportunity
there and 144,000 people don't have to
come to this southern border to try to
find it here I believe that's a smarter
more effective and more humane way to
approach immigration than the way we've
done it and let me just you know finish
this answer by saying that some people
asked me well you know why in the world
was this the first policy proposal that
you made and this is an issue that's
personal to me I grew up with a
grandmother who came over here from the
United States when she was seven years
old from Mexico with her little sister
and they came because their parents had
died and she ended up on the west side
of San Antonio she raised my mom is a
single parent she was basically like a
second mother to me
she came here like I bet a lot of your
parents and grandparents did or maybe
some of you have with hardly anything
and this country provided her the
opportunity to work hard to provide for
her daughter to see her daughter be the
first to graduate from high school and
then go on to college and then just two
generations after she got to the United
States one of her grandson's my twin
brother Joaquin is a United States
congressman and the other one is running
for president of the United States that
is America that is what
[Applause]